the Kalahari
the largest expanse of sand on the
planet
at its Center lies a living breathing
miracle
the yakavango delta
each year when the land is at its driest
distant rainfall fills its veins once
again
the great flood is the heartbeat
[Music]
transforming this land
into a wildlife Paradise like none on
Earth
[Music]
foreign
the land is dry
the rivers have vanished and the flood
is yet to come
flocks of hungry quillia scow the
floodplains by the thousands
the grasses have withered and died
now only their seeds lie dormant in the
dry sand
[Music]
a Scramble for food is underway
foreign
[Music]
these dry unbroken floodplains are the
ideal hunting grounds for a cheetah
especially a Mother with three growing
cups to feed
[Music]
foreign
s are completely dependent on her for
food
[Music]
and Impala would make the perfect meal
but the Cubs are still too young to hunt
they'll stay behind to watch
and learn
she's a skilled Hunter
approaching in silence
Impala horns can be lethal
she cannot afford to make a mistake
speed yes but agility too
these are the cheetah's greatest assets
thank you
it's a dangerous takedown
but she knows precisely how to kill
foreign
he is learning fast
[Music]
his sister is a little less confident
for now feeding her family is easy
but when the flood comes
it will be another story
to survive in this dry season
timing is everything
and the leopard is to tie me as the
cheetah is to speed
[Music]
just when most plants have withered and
died
that's when kagelia trees burst into
life
[Music]
their deep red flowers are filled with
sweet nectar
vervet monkeys are enticed to drink
and they help pollinate the trees
in a land that has grown so dry
the juicy blossoms are Simply
Irresistible
[Music]
a velvet carpet covers the ground
drawing the Impala to join the feast
and it's the Impala that this leopard is
after
[Music]
she'll wait until the monkeys leave
there can be no Witnesses
[Music]
now is the time to make her move
silently
[Music]
funny
the leopard's Ambush is set
all she must do
[Music]
thank you
the Impala have no idea who's about to
drop by
[Music]
thank you
the leopard is shortly the most cunning
of cats
[Music]
every year in Highlands far to the North
heavy rains fall
[Music]
[Applause]
from a trickle to a flow
[Music]
this is the great floods
first pulse
filling the veins and arteries of this
thirsty land
it rejuvenates the barren Sands
and brings the promise of renewal
this wave of water will transform
everything
as a great Oasis is born
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
of water beckons on the Wind
drawing herds of grazers back to their
winter pastures
[Music]
for thousands of Kate Buffalo the flood
rolls out a green life-sustaining
banquet
some travel many miles to get here
the resident Lions lie in weight
foreign
[Music]
weary mother there is no rest yet
her calf now faces the most powerless
challenge of its life
[Music]
but the harder they try
the harder this mother fights
everyone
backup is not far away
that's one advantage of living in a herd
[Music]
just in time the other Buffalo rallied
to her cause
them all
[Music]
the lions are outnumbered and outmatched
by a herd that stands shoulder to
shoulder
foreign
together this Fortress of Buffalo cannot
be breached
and for now
mothers and calves are safe
[Music]
night and day the flood's fingers feel
deeper and deeper into the delta
spreading out and feeding the land
[Music]
channels once empty
now overflow with the abundance of life
as water and land merge have become one
a new world takes shape beneath the
surface
[Music]
here migrants find a welcoming home
wild dogs Revel in The flood's Healing
Waters
the emerging swamp makes a great
playground
oh
but there's something strange lurking
here
and they can't resist investigating
foreign
[Music]
for a giant rock python a wild dog pup
would make a tasty meal
[Music]
the wild dogs are wary of this unknown
visitor
foreign
when in doubt the best approach is To
Live and Let Live
[Music]
in the cold of Winter the great flood
has saturated the land
now begins one of the acavango's
greatest spectacles
[Music]
forms of tiny insects fill the air
midgets and mayflies
[Music]
their emergence is a vital source of
protein
another generous gift of the all-giving
flood
[Music]
even the quelia forego their usual diet
of seeds
thank you
[Music]
other insects are drawn to the feast
dragonflies and their smaller cousins
damsel flies
[Music]
over a hundred different species gather
here
foreign
becomes home to one of the biggest
concentrations of their kind anywhere on
Earth
they are here not only to feed but to
mate
the male makes the first move
[Music]
clasping his partner behind her head
she bends toward him to receive his
sperm
they can remain locked in their
heart-shaped embrace
for hours
[Music]
the male will keep a firm grip on the
female until she deposits their eggs
[Music]
foreign
courtesy of the flood
[Music]
in just a few months billions of gallons
of water in golf what was a vast
Savannah
[Music]
as the flood reaches its peak only small
Islands break the surface
and dry land is hard to come by
[Music]
there are some antelope
that thrive in wetlands
lechway with their long hind legs can
easily outrun any pursuers in this swap
other animals find their own ways to
adapt
[Music]
thank you
but if you're a giant water is no
barrier
[Music]
the fly brings new food
and the elephant's needs are greater
than most
uh
[Music]
foreign
they act as tree surgeons
removing the weakest
[Music]
the sound of a falling tree rings out
like a dinner bell
foreign
and very little will be wasted
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
in a few hours only a skeleton remains
[Music]
swordgrass chokes the waterways
keeping this in check is another job for
the Constant Gardener
an elephant can rip out the grass by the
root
[Applause]
[Music]
rinse it off
and eat it by the time
[Music]
hello
the elephant's insatiable appetites make
them The Architects of the swamp
by managing vegetation they direct the
flow of water
[Music]
foreign
even more construction work is done
and the hippopotamus is the yakavango's
greatest engineer
thank you
hippos of natural-born earth-moving
machines
with their massive lumbering bodies they
reconstruct the Underwater World simply
by moving
everybody
[Music]
the flood's main arteries are now deep
channels
and hippos are right at home
[Music]
they are the masters of this realm
not even crocodiles dare to challenge
them
[Music]
foreign
able to hold their breath for up to five
minutes hippos are perfectly adapted to
their workplace
thank you
as they move in search of food they Bowl
those paths through the vegetation
[Music]
soon there's a network of hippo-sized
highways
[Music]
linking the larger rivers to the smaller
pools
[Music]
where these highways lead the water
follows
[Music]
hippos direct the flow
creating the watery web that shapes the
entire Delta
on the flat open flood Plains the water
begins to slow
[Music]
water lilies thrive in the shallows
they root in thick mud and their
candelabra stems reach for the sky
[Music]
the lily pads spread across the surface
fragile and paper thin
but for one special word
the pads are floating home
[Music]
this is the Lily trotter
with oversized feet he can skip across
the water from pad to pad
the life in the swamp is a delicate
balance
his home is being invaded by a giant
one who's eating habits could wreck this
world
[Music]
foreign
s and lily pads are of little interest
to this elephant
it's the nutritious stems and Roots he's
after
[Music]
to satisfy his appetite he'll yank out
hundreds of them in a day
[Applause]
[Music]
but this Lily trotter can simply escape
to a different part
this is home
and he has a nest to protect
[Music]
he's a father who takes his domestic
responsibility seriously
his mate laid her eggs
and then she left the rest up to him
now he's a single parent and a
stay-at-home dad
he's been tending his floating nest for
21 days
[Music]
but today he must rise to a new
challenge
[Music]
there's no mistaking those legs
his first chick is making us somewhat
awkward entrance
[Music]
housekeeping is a priority
to hide any evidence of the new young
one
he removes the shell from The Nest
breaks it up and sinks it
[Music]
now he'll keep his first chick safely
tucked away
[Music]
it might take two more days before his
others hatch
[Music]
hold on tight
on time
[Music]
this devoted dad now has two chicks
he keeps a watchful eye on the newly
hatched Lily Trotters as they find their
footing
when you're only two inches tall
obstacles are everywhere
[Music]
exploring this watery world can be
tricky
a gap between the past presents a
serious water hazard
[Music]
tries he might dad is only making things
worse
while his chick struggles
[Music]
desperate times demand Desperate
Measures
[Music]
that was a close call
taking both chicks under his wing he'll
keep them out of trouble
for now
foreign
but even for a hard-working dad like
this one a third chick will be a real
handful
[Music]
the great flood has changed everything
it touched
the world has turned
new creatures lurk in the dappled light
of the swamp
[Music]
lions are no longer in command
come on
they don't mind getting their feet wet
but with their hunting ground submerged
they've lost their usual advantages
[Music]
foreign
perhaps it's better to go after
something a little slower
[Music]
the Lions tried to corner a lone hippo
if he reaches deep water he'll be in his
element
and they'll be out of theirs
[Music]
he makes his move before they can make
theirs
[Music]
and he's safe
the flood has brought challenges
and promise
foreign
[Music]
an even greater changes lie ahead
four months after it began the flood is
at its peak
billions of gallons of water have now
spilled into the Kalahari
[Music]
[Applause]
creating a vast Wetland that fans out
for thousands of square miles
[Music]
overflows with life
there
beneath the surface a whole new world
has taken root
[Music]
Secret Gardens flourish
lilies
[Music]
and even the largest residents have all
the space they need
[Music]
thank you
the great flood is the gift that keeps
on giving
crocodiles are in their element waiting
in the shallows of the swap
foreign
s cautiously navigate there now
unfamiliar territory
to patrol what was once all theirs they
must Cross the Swamp
thank you
[Music]
these brothers must stick together
and watch each other's backs
but they're entering a place of unseen
perils
thank you
today they were lucky
but now they're separated
and alone
lions are no longer Kings here
[Music]
the flood has changed all the rules
the waters remain high for several
months
[Music]
but the arcavango is an inland Delta
countless channels Meander without ever
reaching the sea
[Music]
instead after nurturing the land and its
creatures
the water slowly disappears
Church by the summer sun
[Music]
in this land of continual change
it's time for the next transformation
flashes of color sparkle on the receding
Waters
countless Carmine bee eaters flock to
the newly dried growl
[Music]
these summer visitors are here to find
mates and start families
they get to work digging out their nests
[Music]
foreign
s of their seasonal City are laid out
all attention turns to courtship
[Music]
and with so many rivals around first
impressions are everything
[Music]
posturing with a prize proves you can
provide
[Music]
if you can hold on to it
it's every word for himself
as males try to prove they have the
right stuff
finally winners are declared
and matches are made
but just as they're getting down to
business
and walks trouble
an intruder slithers into the city of
Carmines
a monitor lizard on the lookout for eggs
and chicks
foreign
[Music]
s are forgotten as the Carmines form a
united front
[Music]
they'll do whatever it takes to
safeguard the Next Generation
[Music]
thank you
turning the tables on the chancer they
send him packing
[Music]
as the land begins to dry there are
opportunities for those who can seize
the Tactical advantage
wild dogs work the edge of the swamp
[Music]
they're a coordinated team
with a cunning strategy
slowly they push the Impala to the water
until there's only one place left to go
the dog's trap is set
or is it
they aren't the only ones with eyes on
this price
foreign
the dogs are about to be robbed
thank you
crocodile host
fact
but there's strength in numbers
and the pack gains the upper hand
brains and Target determination wins out
this time
but the dogs must always be on their
game in this constantly changing world
[Music]
foreign
this family is up early
[Music]
even in Paradise it's the early bird
that gets the worm
so they're off with the dawn
[Music]
fresh Delicacies emerge as the channels
dry out
[Music]
the falling water levels reveal lilies
and sedges
[Music]
it takes patience and hard work
but it's worth the effort
[Music]
thank you
there's plenty of food here for the
whole Troop
and the neighbors
foreign
keeps a watchful eye
abundance can breed Discord
[Music]
in a growing baboon troupe young Mayors
pushed their limits trying to fight
their way up the ranks
right
it's up to the boss to restore order
[Music]
the squabbling has drawn unwelcome
attention
internal tensions are brushed aside
[Music]
time for this family to move on and find
somewhere safer to feast
attack
as the sun evaporates the water from
above
the vegetation siphons It Off from Below
with falling water levels some residents
need to relocate
a young male hippo has outgrown his pool
this one
out of his element
but he'll trudge for Miles if he has to
[Music]
he's just looking for a place to live
foreign
but he could be wading into trouble
[Music]
this pool already has a tenant
big bull
and he doesn't want a roommate
thank you
the youngster will have to keep looking
deep water is now Prime real estate
Worth Fighting For
vast floodplains filled with water when
the okavango spills over its banks
creating Rich breeding grounds for a
wide range of Aquatic Life
now as they begin to dry these Hidden
Treasures are exposed
[Music]
foreign
build storks are the first to flock in
[Music]
they have just the tools to tackle
another of the floods seasonal off-roads
[Music]
with bills like nutcrackers they forage
for snails in the shallows
[Music]
thank you
millions of small fish that hatched out
here on the floodplains
are now leaving their nursery for deeper
waters
[Music]
black egrets arrive in Hot Pursuit
Church
these birds work undercover
they form umbrellas with their wings
casting Shadows that mimic water lily
pads
the perfect place for little fish to
hide
[Music]
thank you
the illusion is fatal
[Music]
with attacks coming from all sides
the small fish make their escape
they crowd the edges of the channels in
Long ribbons and make their way Upstream
but up ahead
others are waiting
[Music]
while large fish wait in ambush
Shoals of small fish run the deadly
gauntlet
and are picked off one by one
survival in the drying Delta is a game
of hit and miss
[Music]
foreign
channels start to run dry
sand banks are exposed
the perfect nesting size for African
skimmers
[Music]
Nature has endowed them with extended
lower beaks perfect for catching small
fish
summertime on the Delta and the fishing
is fine
[Music]
synchronized squadrons ride to the air
in perfect formation
[Music]
a skimmer's bill slices the water until
it encounters a fish then snap
[Music]
back at the nest the Anglers partner
guards a precious Secret
[Music]
their newborn is ready for its first
meal
[Music]
food must be passed from beak to Tiny
beak
if it's dropped the parents can't pick
it up from the sand
[Music]
this might take a while
but Dad will persevere
keep his grip on the groceries
even if it takes all day
[Music]
finally
patience really is a virtue
[Music]
the sandbanks have become a nursery for
little skimmers
and lots of busy new parents are going
through the same routine
[Music]
skim catch
feed
repeat
[Music]
the abundance of fish is the receding
floods parting gift to them all
[Music]
the acavangos once watery world has
disappeared into memory
[Music]
evaporated into the sky above or
absorbed by the land below
only small channels and pools still
remain
what was floodplain is now Savannah
covered with succulent young grasses
foreign
ERS move in to enjoy the Harvest
the Lions Now find solid footing
[Music]
they've returned
this time with young cubs into
[Music]
with no swamp left for the antelope to
escape into
the lions are back in business
[Music]
the dry floodplains are a lion's
Paradise
foreign
with food in abundance it's easy for a
mother to provide for her family
she and her Cubs can eat their fill
Ed
[Music]
and in this time of Plenty her Pride
will grow ever stronger
oh
as the flood makes its final retreat
only permanent channels in the north are
still flush with water
foreign
[Music]
the banks
the floating root beds Sway in the
current and filter nutrients from the
water
they also provide lodgings for some very
strange little fish
murmuraids have large brains in their
awfully shaped heads
they send out tiny electrical pulses to
orientate through their murky
surroundings
oh
the young fish emit pulses too small to
be detected by most predators
but now most of them have matured and
they are now firmly on the radar of
bigger fish
foreign
catfish have picked up their signals
and so begins one of the okavango's
largest feeding frenzies
massing in vast schools the catfish race
along the edge of the papyrus
and Gorge themselves on murmurits oh
secrets and Eagles are drawn to The Fray
tiger fish hunt the murmuries From Below
only to find themselves targeted from
above
even the hunters become Hunted
no wonder it's chaotic
this deadly spectacle is unequaled
anywhere on Earth
foreign
ERS are soaring
now the okavango summer heat reaches its
peak
the land is bone dry
but the humidity is rising too
and the elephants know there's rain on
the horizon
[Music]
it's the perfect time for their babies
to be born
and other elephants are ready to mate
their hormones raging
goals in must are very aggressive
they're spoiling for a fight
as the aquavongo dries out tensions rise
and bull elephants compete for the right
to meet
whoa
[Music]
sparring escalates to full-blown combat
[Applause]
foreign
Victory is declared
[Music]
lightning storms Herald the approach of
rain
but with the land still as dry as tender
fire is born
foreign
[Music]
the Flames trigger the next stage of the
acavango's miraculous cycle
where a giant Papyrus once dominated dry
Peak beds are consumed in The Inferno
they release valuable nutrients
ready to be washed back into the system
when the rains arrive
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
relief is here
the wheel keeps turning
the cycle of wet and dry
pulls sway over all life in the Yoke of
angle
foreign
[Music]
revives the Thirsty land
for a while
hi me everything
grasses and flowers burst into life
insect insect flourish
and a new generation of Carmine bee
eaters has fledged right on time
good
[Music]
in this world of feast and Fannin
seasonal change triggers an intricate
sequence of miraculous events
soon the short summer rains will end and
the yakovango will be dry for a few more
months
until the cycle begins again for the
return
of the great flood
[Music]
thank you